>> It's an honor
to have Tuomas Sandholm
here today from CMU.
Tuomas is Professor of
Computer Science at CMU.
He did his PhD work, is this on?
I can hear myself
booming in my ears,
but I could say it louder.
So, he did his PhD work
at University of
Massachusetts at Amherst,
and then did a brief tour
at Washington University,
and then onto
professorship at CMU.
Among Tuomas' many honors are
IJCAI Computers
and Thought Award,
The Inaugural ACM Autonomous
Agents Research Award,
The Alan Newell Award for
Research Excellence at
CMU, The Sloan Fellowship,
The Carnegie Science
Center Award for Excellence,
Edelman Laureateship, and
The NSF Career Award.
He's a fellow of
ACM-AAAI and INFORMS.
He's not really old enough to
hold any honorary degrees,
but he holds
an honorary doctorate
from the University of Zurich,
how did that happen?
That's interesting.
>> They made a mistake.
>> Okay. Now, if you
watched the fireside,
we just did our
fireside chat interview
and if you watched that,
this is as an attractor.
We talk about
Tuomas's famed history
as a wind surfing champion,
including winning
the champion windsurfer-ship
in Finland in 1986,
I think it was, but he has
a long history of
being a sports person.
Even playing under the emblem
of the Finnish Air Force,
as a windsurfer.
That's what you get
out of the service,
you just windsurf
your way through
your service in the military.
When I see Tuomas, sharp,
in a little sport coat like this,
I think about a really
wonderful experience
we had when Tuomas visited us.
It must have been
1999, or something-.
>> Ninety-eight, I think.
>> Ninety-eight and we went on
Jack Breezes boat for dinner
across the lake on
a beautiful day,
and about halfway across
the lake towards,
I think it was Daniel's Broiler,
it started absolutely
pouring out.
We were kinda just
in windbreakers,
but Tuomas looked
exactly like this.
In the pouring rain standing
in front of the boat,
and came in looking quite dapper,
but we all knew that
his clothes was
a different shade
when he walked into,
to sit down for dinner in
his soaking wet sport coat.
With that little story
and then yet,
Tuomas to talk about
Super-Human AI
for Strategic Reasoning, Tuomas.
>> Thanks a lot for
having me again,
it's great to be here.
I seem to come here
every few years.
Can you hear me okay in
the back? All right, great.
So, I'm going to talk about
Super-Human AI for
Strategic Reasoning.
Mostly, I'm going to talk about
Libratus and the techniques
that went into it,
which we recently published in
Science with my PhD
student Noam Brown,
and then in the end
I'm going to talk
about some of the other
things that are going
on these topics in my lab
and applications and so on.
All right, and by the way,
do ask questions along the way.
So, imperfect-information
games are
very unlike Chess or Go.
Where in Chess or Go you
know exactly what
the state of the world is.
In Imperfect-information
games you don't.
They're much more like
negotiation, or poker,
or military settings, or
video games and so forth.
So, you all have probably heard
about AlphaGo and AlphaZero.
It's a great success story
and a very complex game.
Those techniques can in principle
apply to other perfect
information games,
and in fact, they have
shown very good success.
For example, in Chess,
and Shogi and so on.
However, they don't apply to
Imperfect-information
games at all.
So, in Perfect-information games,
you can solve a sub-game of
the game tree based on information
in the sub-game alone.
So, for example, in Chess,
how you play
the Sicilian defense is
completely independent of how
you should play
the Queen's gambit.
This is not true in
Imperfect-information games,
and to highlight this difference
let me run through an example.
This is a small example
we call, Coin toss.
This also shows a general
representation of how do you
represent
Imperfect-information games in
a game independent way.
This is called the
extensive form,
which is a standard
representation in game theory.
All right, so, how this
works, this example,
and by the way this
is a tiny game
just for illustrative purposes,
the real games are huge.
So, we have three players,
there's Chance, Player
1 and Player 2.
Chance really just acts
stochastically,
not strategically.
Let's say in this game
Chance just flips a coin,
heads or tails, 50-50.
Then Player 1 can either
sell the coin or play,
and if Player 1 plays,
then Player 2 gets a move,
gets to guess which
way the coin came out.
Heads, tails, or
Player 2 can just
give up and say,
"Well, I don't know.
You win." The payoffs
are shown from
Player 1's perspective.
Player 2's payoff is just
the negative of that.
So, if Player 2
guesses correctly,
Player 1 gets minus one,
and if Player 2 guesses
incorrectly or forfeits,
Player 1 gets one.
Okay? Now, unlike
Perfect-information games,
there's this extra structure
here called the information set.
Often times noted
by this dashed line
or this purple ellipse.
That just represents
a fact that when
Player 2 has his turn to move,
he doesn't know whether he's in
the left blue node or
the right blue node.
He has to infer
that information from
Player 1's strategy,
which Player 2 doesn't know.
Okay? So, what is
rational play here?
Well, I've shown one Nash
Equilibrium of the game here.
A Nash Equilibrium, in general,
is a profile of strategies,
one strategy for each player,
where no player can improve
their expected utility by
deviating to
a different strategy.
What's a strategy? Well,
it's just a mapping from
information sets to
action probabilities
at that information set.
An Epsilon Nash Equilibrium is
a strategy profile
where no player can
improve more than
epsilon, in expectation.
Note that in Nash
Equilibrium the beliefs are
derived on the fly as
we go down the game,
from the equilibrium, and the
observation so far
using Bayes rule.
So, this is in some sense,
game theory is a generalization
of Bayesian reasoning,
and it's the generalization
of MDPs, so,
this is really
a generalization of
POMDPs into
a multi-agent setting.
All right, so, one equilibrium
here is where Player
1 goes 50-50 sell and play,
by the way, here I'm now
assuming the sell option
is worth zero.
So you can throw away the coin,
you don't get anything for it,
then you don't have to
pay to get rid of it.
Here 50-50, and Player 2 guesses
heads half of the time and
tails half of the time.
All right? This is not
the only equilibrium.
Turns out that there's
an uncountable number of
equilibria even in
this simple game.
Okay. Now, to make my point,
I'm going to argue that
this Subgame here,
in this purple rectangle
can't be solved with information
from the Subgame only.
So, if this were
a complete information game,
or perfect information game,
this could be.
Most of the algorithms
like Minimax Search,
Alpha-Beta Pruning and so on,
they are based on the idea
that you can solve the Subgame
and do solve the Subgame based on
information only in the Subgame.
This can't be done here.
So, now, first, I'm
going to say that
the payoffs for selling are
two and minus two respectively.
In that world, what
would Player 1 do?
>> Sell the heads.
>> Sell with the heads, yes, and?
>> Play with the tails.
>> Play with tails, that's right.
So, when Player 2 gets a move,
Player 2 knows that it's tails.
So, Player 2 can get tails,
it's a guess tails and win
whenever it was tails.
Now, if I flip the payoffs
in these triangles
now, you'd get the opposite,
and Player 2 should guess
heads whenever he gets a turn.
So, that just proves
that how Player 2 should
play depends on information
that's outside of the Subgame,
namely in these triangles,
and here it's a simple example,
those triangles could
be arbitrarily big and
have transfer effects in the
game from very far away.
Try to remember this game
because I'm going to
use this as a running
example later on.
Any questions from
the game itself?
Okay. So, when we tackle
imperfect-information games,
we can't use techniques for
perfect-information games.
We develop application-independent
techniques.
So, these are not
poker techniques, and also,
they're algorithmically
creating the strategies.
So, we're not programming
the strategies by hand
or anything like that.
Challenges here,
well, uncertainty
about what others
and chance will do.
But more importantly,
uncertainty about what others
and chance have already done.
That gives me hidden state.
Then I have to think
about what do my actions
signal to my opponents about
my private information?
What do my opponents'
actions signal to
me about the opponents'
private information?
The really cool thing
here is that we don't
have to assume a meaning
for the signals.
That automatically falls out of
the classic solution concepts
in game theory,
like Nash equilibrium
and it's refinements.
So, the real work
here is to marry
those classical solution
concepts with algorithms so
we can compute something that's
near a Nash Equilibrium.
So poker itself, that has been
a recognized challenge problem
in game theory, Or,
and AI for decades,
and if you actually go back
to John Nash's PhD thesis,
which actually look very
short and you showed,
where he introduced
Nash equilibrium,
which really transformed all of
economics and
many other sciences,
the one and only example
there was poker.
But that was a poker
game called Kuhn poker,
which has three cards in
the deck and only one
card in each of the
two players hands.
So, it's a very
small form of poker.
So small that you can actually
solve it by hand, paper, and pen.
Then, there's been steady
progress in poker,
but really there's been
tremendous explosion in
work on using poker as
a benchmark over
the last 14 years.
Hundreds of papers,
I'm not going to
try to do a full
literature review.
I'm going to mention
three highlights here.
One is Rhode Island Hold'em.
This is a game that
has three billion
nodes in the game tree,
and we were able to solve
it exactly in 2005.
So, this was about
four or five orders of
magnitude bigger than what
had been solved before.
The key idea here was
lossless abstraction.
So, you can actually
algorithmically walk
through the game tree,
get rid of 99 percent
of it roughly,
and you get a game,
which you solve, and then you get
an exact answer to
the original game.
So, in some sense, there are
so many weird isomorphisms
in these games,
but you can get rid of all of
them and still get
an exact solution,
although you're
solving a game that's
only one-one-hundredth
of the size.
Then, with Simplex's
LP solver in 25 days,
in a small supercomputer,
we were able to solve that
abstracted game to get an answer.
Then the Annual Computer
Poker Competition
started in 2006,
where different teams
around the world
compete on the same benchmarks,
and you can measure progress year
to year and group to group,
and that has really fueled
progress in the field
because most of the top teams
have been publishing
their results and building
on each other's work.
Then, Limit Texas Hold'em
was near optimally
solved by boiling it all in 2015.
That's another science paper,
and that's a game that has,
after lossless abstraction,
10 to the 13 information sets,
10 to the 13 decision points.
This was the heads-up variant,
which is two-player,
and limit means that whenever
it's your turn to move,
if you bet, there's
a fixed amount you can bet.
There's no choice as
to how much you bet,
and that means that
the branching factor is two or
three depending on the situation.
Now, Heads-up No-Limit Texas
Hold'em is a whole other animal.
This has become the main
benchmark and challenge problem
in AI for imperfect
information game solving.
It has 10 to the power of
161 different situations a player
can face, information sets.
For this audience, I
probably don't need to
explain what that number means,
but it's more than the number
of atoms in the universe,
and even if you had a whole other
universe for every atom in
the universe and counted
those, it's more than that.
So, you're not about to
store this anywhere,
and you're not about to traverse
this game tree even once.
So, you need some totally
different techniques.
This is mostly played
on the Internet,
but it's also played on TV
and in the top poker movies.
Many people consider
this a purest
form of poker because
it's really two players,
so there are no third players
or fourth players that
they're going to mess it up.
It's really am I better
or is Max better?
Just like chess. No prior AI
has beaten top
humans at this game.
All right. So, how many of
you actually know this game?
Okay. So, not everybody.
So, I'm going to walk through
this a little bit
to the extent you
need to know how the rules
work. Just on one slide.
So, first, Chance
deals two cards in
private to each player,
both players.
Then, there's a round of betting.
Then, Chance deals
three shared cards
face-up on the table.
Then, there's
another round of betting.
Then, Chance deals one shared
card face up on the table.
Then, there is
a round of betting.
Then, there's a fourth round
where Chance deals
one more shared card
on the table and
a round of betting. All right.
So, at this point, what we have,
the player's holding two cards in
private and five public
cards on the table.
What you try to do is make
the best five-card hand
out of those seven cards,
and whoever has
the better five-card hand
wins the whole pot.
The hard part is the betting.
So, you have to decide
whether to bet or not,
and if the opponent has bet,
whether to call, fold,
or bet even more, which
is called raising.
If somebody folds, they
lose a pot right there.
If only both players come
all the way to the end,
do you actually
compare the hands?
So, that's how it works.
When I say 10 to the 161,
I mean one play of the game
just as shown on the slide.
So when we play, let say,
120,000 repetitions,
it's not counting
the repetitions,
just one hand of poker
is 10 to the 161.
Any questions so far? Yes.
>> Without us bluffing,
you factored into this.
>> Well, let me-
I will answer that at the end
if that's still unclear.
Okay. So, in January 2017,
I organized this Brains
versus AI Rematch,
and I am calling it a
rematch because I had
organized a similar match
in April 2015,
where we took on four of
the top humans at this game
and we couldn't beat them.
It's very close.
Statistically speaking,
it was actually
statistically insignificant,
so a statistical type but we
couldn't beat them and
they ended up ahead.
So now, we have these new AI
called Libratus.
It's Latin, stands for balanced,
for Nash equilibrium and
powerful for its forth
full play style.
That took a while to figure
out that Latin name.
Anyway, so we played
against four of
the best heads of No-Limit
Texas Hold'em specialist pros.
So these are
professionals not just at
poker but at this
particular form of poker.
It is very important,
because, you know,
these guys are way stronger than
a typical general TV pros
that you might
see at this particular kind
of poker which is two player.
We played 120,000 hands over
20 days in January 2017,
so each one of them
played 30,000 hands.
It is important that you
play a lot of hands
for two reasons.
One, you don't want this
to be decided by luck;
you want it to be
statistically significant.
In 2015, we played
80,000 hands and it was
not enough to get 95 percent
statistical significance,
which is the threshold we use in
the annual computer
poker competition.
So now, my worry was that if
we were a little bit behind,
or even a lot behind the
humans back then, now,
humans had probably
progressed a little
bit but hopefully we
had progressed more,
so it should have
been even closer.
So, I felt that we would need
even more hands to get
statistical significance.
It would have been
a shame to have
another event where we can't
really declare a winner.
The other reason is
that you want to give
the humans the best
possible chance to
find weaknesses in the AI and
exploit those weaknesses.
So, you may have heard about
the Dota 2 bots which are able
to beat top humans for a while,
and then when humans get
to play with them more,
even average humans
can beat them.
So, you want to make sure
this is not just
some sort of a transient,
that for a while you can
beat them when they do not really
know your holes. I will
come back to that.
>> Question.
>> Yeah.
>> How many hours are
there in playing because-?
>> They got to choose
all the parameters.
Actually, I have a whole slide,
we can talk about
that in the Q&A part,
but they chose 20 days.
We sit at poker, how many days
do you want to play over?
This was a given, but
everything else they chose.
How many days, when
to take breaks,
break days, hours of the day;
they got to choose,
even dynamically.
Like on one day
they said, "Oh man,
one of our players
feels really tired,
maybe they are getting
a cold. Let them not play."
So, we said, "Okay
yeah, this afternoon,
we don't play" and so on.
What it ended up being an
average maybe excluding breaks,
maybe about eight hours a day.
With breaks, maybe 10
hours a day,
which is way less than
what they normally play.
So, sometimes
these guys play like
three days straight. Yeah.
>> Did you compare
the random number generator for
chance maybe to get
higher statistical significance?
>> I'll come to that. We did
a conservative experiment design
where we let them
pick almost all of
the parameters of the tournament
so we wouldn't get into
a crossfire of like
whining thing at the end
in case we would win.
I have a slide on
all those parameters
if you are really
interested in that.
>> Did you use the information
over his gains with the pros?
>> I'll come to that.
>> Okay.
>> How the AI works. First,
I'll talk about the match and
then I'll talk about
how the AI works.
>> The queue of
questions hovering here.
>> Yes. Most of
which I am skipping.
It is great to take
questions if you don't
have to answer them.
So, this is what it looks like.
So, here we have
my PhD student Noam,
some of the casino personnel.
Here is our dean
looking very worried.
He told me up front that if you
don't win this time you're fired.
I hope he was joking. I
did not want to test him.
Here's Jason Les one of the pros,
and here's Daniel
McAulay, one of the pros.
But you see only two
of the pros here.
Where are the other two?
So, this is a casino floor.
These guys are playing in public,
the other two are playing in
a private isolation chamber
on the second floor,
where per your question,
we are actually doing
duplicate matches.
So whatever hand Daniel
gets against the AI,
his paired human in that match,
the AI gets that
against the human.
So, neither the humans
nor the AI can
systematically get lucky because
they are essentially
getting the same hands.
Of course, you have to
keep them in isolation;
otherwise, they could
tell each other
what hands are coming next.
All right. So, we are
having some fun with Jason.
This is what it looks like.
They actually chose to
play two tables at once.
So a left table, right table
and these are different hands,
and they can choose to
play like one, one, one,
one or play all of
the hands of a session
here, and then here,
but they like to do
this because they're
used to playing multi-table,
and they can then let
their brains to one some of
the tough questions in one table,
while making progress
on the other table.
So, this is one of the
parameters that they selected.
Here you have a chat window
which they could choose
individually whether
to keep on or not.
So, whether the audience could
actually interact with
them, and Jason loved it,
he felt that he plays
best when the audience
is cheering him on,
and for mankind.
Some of the other humans
felt that "No,
no, I am going to turn it off.
I want to just focus and I am
best when I am just focused."
>> Peoples do and I've questions
and they take your time to
share, they go back and forth.
>> Yeah.
>> Is there a called
responsiveness people have,
whether they actually
stew for a while.
>> Depends on the hand.
So, most times
are very easy to play.
So, most times they
just know how to play
optimally very quickly,
and then there are
some difficult times
where they take more time.
We had no time limit
for the humans.
So, actually, the timing
was interesting.
We got a lot of angry comments
on the chat saying,
"Oh, the bot thinks too long."
Well, it turns out
that on average the humans
thought 20 seconds,
the bot thought 13.
So, the bot was actually
playing faster than the humans.
But its thinking behavior
was very different.
So, first of all,
the AI didn't think at
all in the first two
betting rounds.
It's basically using
a lookup table,
and then it would tank.
It will stop to think for
30 or 45 seconds in
the beginning of
the third betting round,
which is a very unusual timing
for the humans,
so they got
disoriented with that,
I mean the audience.
The other thing is
that humans generally
think harder when
there's a lot at stake.
So, if there's a lot
of money in the pot,
the humans think harder
than if there's
a little bit of money.
The AI does the exact opposite.
Because the less money
there is in the pot,
the more re-raise
possibilities there are,
and the bigger the gain tree
after that base.
So, the AI would
actually think the
longest when there was
the least at stake,
which was weird for
the audience as well.
Yeah.
>> So, almost the game work
assumes that humans are
perfectly rational,
they are as powerful as
the machine in terms of
solving these trees.
Do you think these guys
are closer to
those assumptions and what
happens if those assumptions
are not [inaudible]?
>> Good, good, good. So, what
if the opponent isn't rational?
Well, there's
a whole other line of
work that has been done in
the field to which we've
contributed also
opponent exploitation,
trying to exploit
weaknesses in the opponent.
But I'm going to talk about why I
decided not to turn
those things on here,
because this Nash equilibrium
approach is safe.
If the opponent does
something as not rational,
it can actually only help me,
because it's a zero-sum game.
So, we wanted to build
an unbeatable AI,
we didn't necessarily want to
exploit the humans by
the biggest possible amount.
Well, now we're going
so many questions,
let me postpone and we
have a lot to cover.
Okay. So, up, before we go
to the bottom line there.
So, people really
believe in people.
So, the international
betting sites put us as
a four-to-one or
five-to-one underdog
on the morning of the event.
So, we were walking into
this as a huge underdog.
But what happened is this,
Libratus beat the top humans
in this game by a lot,
statistical significance at 99.98
percent or a p-value of 0.0002,
or if you like,
finance for Sigma.
So, a very clear victory.
So, my worry that
okay maybe 120,000
hands wouldn't be enough
was totally unfounded.
We had just blown past
the best humans in
the 18 months between the
previous match and this match.
The wind rate was
147 milli big blinds per game or
14.7 big blinds per 100
if you're a poker player.
Each of the humans
individually also lost
to Libratus and this
was a big deal.
So now, before we go
to the techniques.
Then, I got an email from
China saying, '' It's okay.
Well, that was fantastic.
Now, we're in April,
2017. That was fantastic.
I want you to come and do
the same thing in China.''
I'm like, ''Well,
there's no value to it.
We've already beaten
the best humans in the world.
So, there's no scientific values.
So, I don't really think so.
He said, ''It's well
actually you know.''
He was actually one
of our PhD graduate,
a very famous Chinese PhD
graduate from the late 80s,
and he said, ''Well,
in China people don't know
that CMU is so great in AI.
They've heard of Stanford and
Harvard but not so much CMU.
So, why don't you do.
This is going to
be good for CMU."
And I said, ''Okay, we'll
do it as an exhibition,
not a scientific experiment
per se. We'll do an exhibition.
Because they didn't
want to play along,
and my worry is that if we
put some small number of hands,
it's a coin flip and
that would be not good."
So, we played only 36,000
hands against
six Chinese poker players.
By the way, the brand
that we used was
not Libratus we used Lengpudashi,
which was name given to
array by the Chinese team.
I think it means
cold poker master
and these included China's
one and only World Series of
Poker Bracelet winner
and these people had
expertise in computer
science and machine
learning as well, not just poker.
When we got there, we
walked into a trap.
In that, they had somehow scraped
all of the hand
history of the AI.
So, they had 120,000 hands
of sample of how we play,
and we didn't know
this in advance.
Wasn't freely explicitly
forbidden but anyway.
So now, we are facing
a very different opponent.
By the way, so when I got there,
it's three story building
just for this event.
There's this big media studio
with professional poker
commutators on one floor.
There's actually bent on
another floor and then this is
one bottom floor where
there's an elevator
shaft and a door.
So, at one point, I decided
that I'm going to peek in there,
and guess what I saw there.
A long table of analysts on
their computers doing
real-time analysis
of the play and giving
the humans advice.
That wasn't disallowed
either but this is
what we were facing. All right.
So, now Lengpudashi won by
220 milli big blinds per game.
So, even more than we
had one in January
and it also won each of
the nine sessions and beat
each of the humans individually.
So, what does this say?
Well, first of all, it says
that the players we played
in January were really good,
and that they played
better even without
any background history
on how we play.
But the other thing is
really more fundamental.
It's really showing the power of
game theory as opposed to
say reinforcement learning.
In that, the game
theory approach is
thinking about all possible
strategies of the opponent.
So, it doesn't matter that
they know our strategy.
We're basically not exactly
Nash, but approximately Nash.
But an exact Nash
equilibrium would be
unbeatable even if they
know exactly our strategy.
This is unlike what has
been seen in RL approaches.
It's like Go and Dota 2.
So, if you've seen
the Go documentary,
even the European champion
who wasn't really the best in
the world was able to beat
AlphaGo after some
practice with it.
In Dota 2, even
average humans can
beat it once they get
some practice with it.
So, this is a big lesson,
I think. All right.
Maybe there's something
more general in this
as well to go on
a limb a little bit,
maybe for adversarial
machine learning.
maybe this will be some
more game theoretic
thinking, and so on.
I know there's some initial
connections already.
So, how does Libratus work?
Well, the high level point
is provably correct techniques,
so you won't see,
for example, deep learning here.
These are all theoretically
correct techniques.
We were running on Bridges,
which is a newly supercomputer
at the Pittsburgh
supercomputing center.
We were running on
CPUs back then.
We also have GPU codes now.
In the end, time
allowing I'll talk
about something that can
be done on one server,
which is not quite as good,
but the newer technique.
So, the architecture has
really three main pieces.
One is the pre-computation over
what we call a blueprint
strategy for the whole game.
It takes on as input
rules of that game,
runs an abstraction algorithm,
and then runs an approximate
equilibrium finding
algorithm on the abstract game to
come up with a blueprint strategy
for both players
for the whole game.
Then there's a sub-game solver,
which takes the
blueprint and solves
the sub-game that's actually
reached to come up with
a finer grained strategy,
in a finer-grained abstraction.
Now, you might said, ''Wait,
wait a second, Tuomas.
You just told me in the beginning
that this is impossible and
now you're telling
us that you're doing
it. So, what gives?''
I'm going to tell you how
this is actually possible.
The short answer is that
the blueprint gives
enough context that you
can isolate the
sub-games in there,
enough that you can get
provably correct
techniques even in
these imperfect
information games.
Then there's a
self-improvement module.
Notice that this is
not the typical way
of using machine
learning in games,
which is opponent exploitation.
Instead, I thought that,
that would be very risky here.
Because we're playing
against the best humans,
they don't have very big
holes to exploit,
and their world leading experts
at counter exploitation.
So, let's not use those opponent
exploitation techniques,
instead we're doing a new thing
here which is that we are letting
the human's actions tell us where
the humans think
that we have holes,
and then overnight, we are fixing
those holes to play
even more game theoretically
in those spots.
So, that's nice in the sense
that the patches
are then universal.
They apply against all opponents.
This is not a big data story.
You could argue whether this is
a machine-learning story at all,
but if you think about the first
two modules there's no data.
It's a zero data story.
You just taking on the rules
of the game as input.
Here, there's minimal machine
learning as I'll show you.
So, to put this in perspective,
that's a boxing analog.
So, it's like shadow boxing
against the mirror,
and then jumping in
the ring with Mike Tyson
to see what happens.
>> All right. So, now let's
go through these in order.
So, the abstraction
works as follows.
We have the rules of the game.
The game tree is too
big to represent,
so we have the rules
in compact form.
We run a new
abstraction algorithm.
We get an abstracted game
about 10 to the
14 or 10 to the 13.
Then we run
a new equilibrium-finding
algorithm to come up
with an epsilon equilibrium
for the abstracted game.
This is about 50 terabytes
of probabilities,
and then you un-abstract the
answer to play the blueprint
in the original game.
The abstraction has
two kinds of abstraction,
one is chance abstraction
and the other
is abstracting
the player's actions.
Chance abstraction in poker
is abstracting the cards.
We use the same algorithm
that we used in Tartanian8,
which had baby version
on which won
the Annual Poker
Competition in 2016.
But now in a much
finer abstraction
and in particular for
the first two betting rounds,
we had no abstraction.
So, full understanding of
the cards and then in the
latter to wrap betting rounds,
there's abstraction but
by the time we get there,
the in-game solver kicks in,
which doesn't have abstraction.
So, now we never play
with code abstraction at
any point in the game.
Abstracting the player's actions,
which is bet sizes in
the case of poker,
this is largely based
on what top humans
and top AIs from
the past have done,
but we also added
radical bet sizes like
the goal in a tiny
10 percent bets.
Why? Well, we just wanted
to see whether it will ever play
those with probability that's
greater than zero, might as well.
Then we have this first
convergent algorithm for finding
optimal bet side combinations
but it's not very scalable.
So, we were using that only
for the first two bet sizes.
So, we were optimizing
the size of
the first two bet sizes
algorithmically.
Now, what's the new
equilibrium finding algorithm?
Well, it's an improvement on
Monte-Carlo counterfactual
regret minimization.
Now on back what that means,
some of you may already know
that regret minimization
is this technique where you are,
based on your history,
you're trying
to minimize average regret.
Counterfactual means
that you don't do it in
the space of
strategies but you do
it at every information
set separately,
and you have to be careful
how to group those together.
Monte-Carlo means
that you're sampling.
You're not traversing
the whole game tree.
Now, the new thing is
that you start visiting
less often paths where
our own actions don't
look promising.
So, we're our own actions have
very high negative
regret correctly.
This gives you a speedup
because you're
visiting less offering
the bad paths,
so we can solve
larger abstractions.
Also in imperfect-recall
abstractions,
which is a state of
that abstraction,
you have this issue that
many different paths
lead to the same abstract
state in the future.
Now, some of those paths will
effectively get discounted
away with this technique.
So, there's less fighting in
those abstract states as
to what you should do it
because for different paths,
how you got there, you might
want to do different things.
You get actually better
solution quality as well,
not just better speed. All right.
So, now let's talk about
subgame solving and this
is maybe the most novel
part of the architecture.
This is where we take
the blueprint strategy and we
compute a refined strategy in
a finer-grained
abstraction in the subgame
that's reached during play.
If you think about
the timing of this,
think about this being weeks or
months of computation in
advance of the match.
This like 30 or 40 seconds
of computation during the hand,
and this is an overnight process
on let's say 200 servers.
Okay. Now, I'm going to jump
into a little bit of detail here.
So, if you don't follow,
it's okay at after
five or 10 minutes,
we'll get back to the high level.
I'm going to actually do
a transformational analogy
through the history of endgame
solving in imperfect
information games
because there have only
been so few papers,
I can actually go
through the whole thing.
So, new ideas in
the subgame solver.
Probably safe subgame
solving taking
into account the opponent's
mistakes in the hand so far.
So, let's talk about that first
and there I'm going
to do the analogy.
So, the first
techniques for subgame
solving in imperfect
information games were unsafe.
That's what we call
them nowadays.
We didn't call it back then.
So, let's say that this is
the blueprint strategy in
this example coin toss game.
It's not an exact equilibrium
or equilibrium finder.
It didn't give us
an exact answers.
You can see it here, we're 50-50.
Here, we quarter, three-quarters.
Here, there's more heads guessing
and tails guessing and there's
some forfeiting going on.
So, you can see that
that's not really
the best strategy but
it's a decent strategy.
Then what we're trying to do,
we're trying to compute
a better strategy for
Libratus as player two.
Here, I'm going to show
all of these techniques in
the same abstraction
just for simplicity.
In reality, we would
want to change
the abstraction so that we have
a finer grain game tree here
under that player
two information set.
So, the original idea of
unsafe subgame solving is
we just use Bayes' rule.
We assume that player one plays
according to these probabilities
from the blueprint.
So then we get the probabilities
here and here using Bayes' rule.
If you compute the best
strategy to that,
you'll see that player two
would always gets hit.
That's a fine strategy,
if player one indeed
sticks to that strategy up
there but it's of course
highly exploitable in that,
player one could play so that
that's always a bad guess.
Okay. So, no theoretical
guarantees but this just
well in practice in
some domains and it seems that in
bigger domains these type of
problems are less prevalent
or at least less pronounced.
Then the first safe subgame
solving technique was called
re-solve refinement
by Burch et al.
Here is a little bit of
a mind-bending thing,
in that we are allowing
the opponent to make
an action which is
a selection of abstractions.
So, here we have again
the blueprint strategy in
purple and we can look
at what's the expected value
of playing in here,
given player two's
strategy at zero
and here the expected value
of playing is half.
So, now I'm going to
construct this gadget game,
where I'm going to
compute the player
two's strategy for the
subgame as follows.
I'm going to give player
one the choice of
entering the original
abstraction and taking
this expected value or
I'm allowing Player one
to enter the subgame,
which typically would be in
a finer-grained abstraction.
So again, a little bit
on mind-bending thing.
Now, there's an
action that we allow
the opponent to take which is
not the real world action,
it's a selection
between abstractions.
>> All right. Now, Player one
can choose between entering
the subgame or taking
the expected value according to
the blueprint of the subgame.
What we want to make sure here
in the gadget game is that
the opponent's
expected value of entering
the subgame is no higher
than in the blueprint.
If we can guarantee that,
then the strategy is probably
no worse than
the blueprint strategy.
In particular,
if the blueprint was
Nash, this is still Nash.
Any questions on that idea?
Okay. Now, trust me,
here's what would come out
or one of the things that
could come out of your solver,
these purple numbers.Then you
can see that there's
the same numbers as here.
So, it might actually
come up with
the same strategy as a blueprint.
So, what have we
actually accomplished?
It might miss obvious
opportunities for improvement,
for example, never forfeiting.
We know intuitive let
forfeiting is a bad idea.
You might as well make
a guess because it's free.
So, we know that these
forfeiting is a mistake,
and it's still there with
positive probability.
Okay. So, the next improvement to
that was called Maxmargin
refinement by Moravcik et al.
Here we have again, the same
idea, choice of abstraction.
So, this is the same so far.
It's similar to resolve,
but punishes
Player one as much as
possible for choosing
entering rather than out.
So, we define a margin for
every type that
the opponent might have.
So, in auction sheet, it
would be evaluation types.
Here it's heads or tails.
So, for example,
the margin for heads
is expected value of
the alternative of
heads minus the expected value
of entering under heads.
We solve this by maximizing
the minimum margin.
This is in contrast
to the previous slide
where we simply attend to
make all of the margins
non-negative. Yes.
>> What does entering mean like-
>> Interested here.
You are entering
the first game as opposed
to choosing the blueprint.
>> For what do you
do after you enter?
Do you get a reward
upon entering.
Do you have to go all the
way to the leaf of the tree.
Do you let the opponents
choose their move?
>> We are trying to compute
a strategy for Player two.
Here.
In this model we are,
well, let me show you that.
So you will get five heads here,
three heads here, zero here.
So there's no
forfeiting anymore and
the expected value would be
minus quarter here
and a quarter here,
and if you look at the margins,
it's actually
balancing the margins.
So the margin here is
the same as the margin
here. Does it make sense now?
>> No.
>> No? Okay.
>> I still don't understand
what is entering
because entering is a
Player one move, right.
>> Entering is a Player one move.
That is the choice
of abstraction.
Player one can take
the alternative here from
the original
blueprint abstraction
or into this new subgame.
>> I see you're just
trying to maximize if
he were to choose
enter, in some sense.
>> We are trying to
maximize how much he
would lose by going
enter instead of out.
>> Yes. Okay.
>> Yes. Here how much he would
lose is a quarter on
here and a quarter here.
>> I see so I'll
just kind of like,
I don't want to play the game
anymore, let's stop here.
>> No. It's not that.
It's not that I
want to stop here.
It's I want to play according
to our original abstraction.
>> Okay. All right.
That makes more sense.
>> Let me postpone though.
We're running a little late here.
Okay so the newest then, well,
the problem here is that while we
focus on reducing Player
one's expected value for
heads to minus quarter,
Player one can actually
just settle for
half in the hedge situation.
So, he's still somehow
missing something.
The newest idea is what
we call Reach-Maxmargin
refinement,
and now we're solving
a single sub-game first.
We'll talk about
multiple in a second.
Let's focus on
this yellow part here.
I'm not going to show you
the gadget game but here.
Somehow if Player one plays here,
Player one is making
a mistake of half, right.
Player one is giving
us a gift of half.
So, in the gadget game we
can increase the alternative
payoff following
heads by half because
choosing play would still be
a mistake for Player one there.
So we can afford to
give half of gifts,
half which is
the size of the gift
back and it will still be
a mistake or half minus X1.
That's the gadget game solver
focuses on reducing Player
one's expected value for
other type she may have.
So that's the only
extra thing over
the previous slide is that
we're keeping track of
these gifts and we can afford for
some types to give
back something,
and those are exactly
the types where the gift
was positive for
others it was zero,
and we can't afford to
give back anything.
So, this gives us in a way of
bigger polytope to optimize
strategies over in
a safe way. All right.
So, now two flies in
the ointment and this
is kind of a side deal here,
but one is that if
multiple subgames are refined
the off path expected values
might not remain constant.
So, here let's say we have
this thing gift of half here.
Now, if we change,
take the gift here,
say that that's one.
This is half now.
We can also take,
or we can take the
gift here but we can't
take the gift on both sides or
different subgame themselves in
different hands because now
we've made ourselves exploitable.
Solution to this is we
split the gifts among
the subgames by the probability
that subgame is reached.
So, for example here,
if this is half half
we take half of
the gift on this side and half
of the gift on this side.
There are other ways
that are safe
as well but you can't count
the full gift on
all sides because now you
would no longer be safe.
Other fly in the ointment
is that the gifts might
not be as large as
we thought because the subgames
they come from and
will be improved.
So, let's say here,
we thought that gift is half here
but because we're going
to improve the subgame,
the actual gift is only a quarter
and you can substitute the
lower bound on the gift.
It can even be
an estimating practice.
All right, off-tree actions
and nested subgame solving.
Now, this is going to
be kind of mind bending
at that can actually
change the abstraction on
the fly and still have
Nash Equilibrium guarantees.
So, normally when the branching
factor is large in games,
like in North Texas Hold'em,
you actually just put some of
the actions into the model.
We call this action abstraction.
Then we always can play into
the abstraction because
we control our actions,
but the opponent might play
something that's
not in our model.
So, let's say the opponent
plays at green action,
then we pretend that
they actually played
the black action.
This is called the reverse
mapping or action mapping.
How do we map these green actions
back into the abstraction?
There's a whole literature how to
do that, the newest, and latest,
and greatest on
that strand is they've got
13 paper and we'll
benchmark against that.
Now, we want to get
rid of that entirely.
So, what we do is that we
are going to solve a subgame
in real time including
the off-tree action that
the opponent actually took.
So, now we're adding
branches to our
action abstraction or
a game model on
the fly and we'd still
like to be able to prove
equilibrium properties.
So, here's what it
would look like.
So, let say Player one can take
three actions with
expected values X,
Y and Z, but instead
that's in our head,
but in reality they
do something else.
So we actually construct
this same kind of
idea that Player one,
the opponent, can actually
choose between abstractions,
either in the original game
where he gets a maximum of X,
Y and Z, the best of
the original actions,
or this new action
which is generated on
the fly to match
exactly the action
the opponent actually took.
All right. So,
properties of this.
This actually works even
with hidden actions
by chance which you
don't see in poker.
So now let me define delta.
This is not an assumption.
It's a definition of delta.
So, let delta be such
that there exists
a Nash equilibrium where
each alt payoff for
Player one is within delta of
the Nash Equilibrium
expected value
at that point for Player one.
So, that's basically saying,
well, let me leave it at that.
Then our Reach-Maxmargin subway
and solving technique yields
a 2-delta Minimax strategy
for Player two for the full game.
So, this means that we
can actually change or
abstraction on the fly
and we feel almost
optimal and how close
to optimal we are
is how off our blueprint
was from Nash.
If it was an exact Nash,
will still be exact Nash.
Now, there's
another version of this,
which talks about alt
in a different way,
where if player one's alt
payoffs are computed from
a best response in the full game
to player two's blueprint,
then the strategy formulae are
reached max margin subgame
solving technique has
no greater regret than
play for player two in
the full game than
players' two blueprint strategy.
Saying that, okay, this
is not going to make
the blueprint- may make
the strategy worse
than what it was.
Notice that there's
no notion of Delta here,
however bad your blueprint was,
it's not going to get worse.
Nested, these can
actually be reapplied for
every subsequent opponent
of reaction as well.
So, we don't have
to just do it once,
we can apply the same over and
over in the hand as we
get deeper and deeper
into the game.
Theorem one prime is
that now you're not
off by two Delta,
your two Delta times
number of reapplications
within one play-through.
So, if you're applying this
three times, it's six Delta.
Theorem two prime
for this setting,
well, it's the same as two.
So, you're not going to
make the blueprint worse.
All right. Experiments
on medium-sized games.
This is not Texas Hold'em
because there you can't
compute the best response to
evaluate how exploitable you are.
This is a medium-sized
poker game.
Our best reach sub-games
solving technique,
there's actually
multiple variations,
has three times less
exploitability than
the best prior safe
subgame solving
technique and the nested
read subgame solving is 12
times less exploitable and the
best action mapping technique.
So, indeed this idea of
action mapping is dominated
by this nested read
subgame solving.
Okay. Also, the subgame
solving starts much earlier.
Typically, had been
two years by then only.
It had been on
the last betting round,
now we're actually starting it
already on the third
betting round.
There's no card abstraction in
the subgame because
we have these more
scalable subgame solving
techniques and we can actually
change our action
abstraction between hands.
Now that we're solving
our subgame some new anyway,
we might as well change
our action abstraction
a little bit.
Because the value
of the game is not
very sensitive to the
action abstraction,
but the strategy is
quite sensitive to it.
This keeps our opponents
on their toes all the
time because they're facing
a different action
abstraction all the time,
and they have to think
through it every time.
Okay. So, now if
you're a poker player,
you know that
these type of subgame
solving would show up in
what's known as blockers.
How do you think
about blocker cards?
If you don't know poker,
don't worry about it.
I'm going to play a video
about the guy who's been
interviewed is Daniel McAulay,
he's one of
the two or the three people
in the world who has
an open promise
that they will play
anybody in the world
at this game.
Notice part of- pay
attention to what he
says when he's called
for an example.
He has just played
30,000 hands of poker,
and he's being asked to recall
an example of
a particular client,
and he just record
it just like that.
>> In contrast to
the first challenge,
there was a lot of hands
the first time around
where the block really
just punted one-off.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> I've seen way less of that,
so what were your thoughts,
how good is the bar?
>> It's pretty good.
I mean, one version.
So, in fact instead of
myself playing good then
it must be pretty good.
There's not really
any punting, I think,
it uses blockers there
on the block spots,
like, I've never picked up
on anything on the studio,
obvious one way or the other.
So, I'm genuinely impressed,
just pretty good.
>> Oh, okay. Maybe it's
next one where we see.
Yeah, it's a later video where
we see the example. All right.
So, let's talk about the last
module of the self-improver.
So, again, I mentioned that
we're not gonna try to
do opponent exploitation here,
although there are
algorithms for it.
But it would be, in my opinion,
it would have been too
risky, so we didn't do it.
We can instead do
a different kind of idea
that I think we were
the first to do.
Where we let
the opponent's actions,
tell us where the opponents
think they've found
holes in our strategy
and then we're going
to fix those holes
overnight to play more game
theoretically in those spots.
So, here's a simple example.
Let's say Libratus moves
first, then the opponent.
These are our action
abstraction in the blueprint.
Let's say the opponent
has actually played
also some of the actions
out of the abstraction.
So, those green actions.
Now, we're going to
automatically prioritize
which of those are
the biggest holes.
It has to do with how close you
are to that prototypical actions,
the blue ones, and how
often they played.
The closer you are,
the less of a problem it is
and the more often it's played,
the bigger the problem it is.
So, let's say that this
is the worst problem.
We call this a top one hole.
Now, we're going to generate
the coarser caught
abstraction for that part,
so we can solve it overnight
instead of months,
and we're going to
put a default action,
one of the already existing blue
actions in there,
in an even coarser abstraction,
so that we don't end
up assuming that
the opponent plays this with
all possible cards that
he might be here with.
Then we're going to
freeze this part
of the blueprint strategy,
and we're going to recompute
this four Epsilon equilibrium
using the same
algorithm overnight.
Then we're going to
throw this one away,
and this gives us a strategy
for a new branch of the game tree
that wasn't there. All right.
We do this for the top k holes.
Depending on how big your game
is and how much
supercomputing you have,
you can do more or less holes.
We typically try to do
two or three holes a night
and then in the morning
we had a test against
our prior AIs
to see whether the whole had
been sufficiently solved.
If so, we would put it in
the execution engine
and if not, then not.
So now, let's see
what the humans say
about the holes and the
self-fixing of the holes.
>> The energy level is super
high the first few days.
It start up in the hole,
kind of expected us for
figuring out what's going on.
Then we climbed all the way back
to basically nearly even,
and we're like, we're in this,
we have a chance.
We had a key strategy ideas,
key things we're
pushing against the AI.
Then, I guess,
the wheels just came
off the wagon and it wasn't
that our play fell
apart in my opinion.
I think we've really seen
a clear improvement in the AI
strategy day-to-day-to-day.
>> Okay. Let's see what see
what Jimmy Chou has
to say about it.
>> The block plays incredible.
The first two or three nights,
I severely underestimated
its ability,
I really thought that we
were just going to find
a couple of simple leaks
and just hammer away at it,
and will just be a easy 20,
20 days, but it's been
a complete opposite.
Every time we find something,
it seems to adjust
the next day and
we have to continue
to look for leaks,
but eventually, that we just
were not able find any.
>> Okay. Head-to-head strength
of the top AIs.
So, higher on
the slide is stronger.
Here are ours on the left,
others on the right.
There are many other AIs, these
are just showing the top ones.
I guess the bottom line
here is that
usually you see an improvement of
maybe 10 or 20 milli big blinds
per game per year,
and here we saw in 18 months
we saw 63 milli big blinds,
which is a big improvement
mostly driven by the
subgame solving.
It didn't even measure
the contribution of
the last component.
Another kind of interesting thing
is that, this Modicum AI,
which is our newest AI,
which is not
the strongest Libratus,
but this was actually
built just on one server.
So, this is not a supercomputing
deal here at all.
So, observations
about Libratus' play.
Well, strengths, it plays
very in an unusual way.
So, if you're looking for
heterogeneity in AIs for games,
this is what you- it's
better to actually have at
least one of the things
be something I've
generated from scratch,
rather than copying
different humans.
Because humans always
play in a subspace
of the game strategy space.
Small bets and huge bets
and huge all-ins
plays a totally different kind of
poker around on humans
had been used to.
Multiple bet sizes in
any one situation,
he must typically play
one or at most two.
It places actions called
limping and donk betting,
which poker books
universally say are bad.
We do them regularly.
Not all the time, but we do
them with good probability.
In all of the AIs, for example,
that we've generated, limping
happens with eight to 12 percent.
So, that suggests that it's
not really a bad action.
Perfect balance.
While Nash would've been perfect,
of course we're not exactly Nash.
But that's what the
humans call it.
Mixed strategy, probability
distributions over
player's hands,
not just range-based thinking,
which is really the supports of
the distributions as
many pros do nowadays.
Near perfect subgame play,
great use of blockers,
different bet sizes using
different subgames.
Weaknesses, well there's
no opponent exploitation,
but that's by choice.
In that, we wanted to make
something that's
very hard to beat,
rather than something
that would exploit
weak players by
the biggest possible amount.
Now, over the 13,
14 years up to
this point that I had
been working on poker.
I'm being a poker
player by the way,
but I started to love
the game over that time.
Then, when we finally
got to this point,
I started worrying it, I'm
not going to ruin the game.
There's many ways to ruin a game.
One of them would
be to say, "Okay,
here's an optimal way of
playing and it's boring."
So, my worry was
that we're going to
find some sort of
strategy that she's
also a little bit
the value here and
there and it's boring.
Let's see what Dong Kim,
he's probably the number one
player in the world currently,
has to say about that.
It's safe play, equilibrium
play in other words,
is a timid or boring.
I apologize, there's some
swearing in this video.
>> But that a lot of people
asked me to ask you guys is,
does the block bluff?
>> The block's got to nick.
>> Block's a nick?
>> Block fucking bluffs.
Do you want me to talk,
am I allowed to say
that? Block bluffs.
>> You're gonna curse on YouTube?
>> Okay, I know that.
But fucking gangster,
for sure. Gangster as fuck.
>> Confirm the board
does roll off.
>> Can you give me an example of
a maybe a crazy bot bluff
that we wouldn't have
seen for a person?
>> Today, he flatted
a full bet with five,
three of clubs, the
four came king, queen,
jack with two hearts,
check check,
hearts on a flush, check check,
got to set the trap,
five level he bets,
iris small, 50 bet charms.
>> That's a pretty gangster hand.
>> He's real gangster,
but he's not messing around.
That's like manly boss,
big bets. It's pretty gangster.
>> Yeah. I think for humans
in lots of the situations,
when it gets no weird lines,
like four-bet pot,
check check, check, check,
and then all sudden,
there's bet rays, three bet,
I think a lot of players
they are a little too
afraid they made a bluff.
I think we can pretty safely say
that's not the case here.
>> Yeah. Maybe I'm
a little afraid and
I'll sure just like,
everyone's ranges is
so weird that it's
very hard to choose
what chance whereas it
can just go this percentage
of those hand or
this percentage of that hand.
So, and every situation,
you'll always question
what kind of bluff
off and then you will realize
that doesn't really matter.
I always has bluffs.
>> Okay. So, I guess that answers
your bluffing question
to an extent at least.
So, now, let me pop up back to
the higher level of
some current research
on this topic in my lab,
and I mean this topic,
as in game solving.
We're doing other things
like kidney exchange,
advertising in markets and
things like that as well,
but now I'll just focus on this.
So, one is lossy abstraction
algorithms with bounds.
So, the abstraction algorithms
that are currently
used in practice,
they don't have bounds
on how much you lose,
unless the loss-less ones,
but they don't abstract enough.
The remaining game is
still too big to solve.
So, now, we have these lossy
abstraction algorithms
with bounds.
After we started
developing those,
I realized that they're
not really about
just abstraction for
computational speed.
They're also the same theory
applies to looking at modelling.
So, all modelling is abstraction.
Now this is talking about
if we can measure the difference
between reality or bound
the difference between
reality and our model,
then we can, for the first time,
say that our game
theoretic strategies have
some bound on how good they
are for the real world,
which is kind of astonishing in
that game theorists have been
doing game theory for many,
many decades yet there
has been no discussion
of how the answers
that come out or
models actually how good
are they for reality.
Now, to do still is,
we need to unify
our best practical abstraction
algorithms with the theory.
So, the theoretical
algorithms are not the
same as the practically
best ones currently.
Simultaneous abstraction
and equilibrium finding.
So, I showed you
this waterflow of all,
which is a traditional
way of doing it,
abstract first then solve.
Here, we are actually
allowing the equilibrium
finder to tell
what traits are similar
in their strategies and
therefore maybe they
shouldn't be separated.
Similarly, so
this an iteration between
abstraction and
equilibrium finding,
and the key then is how do
you actually warm start
the equilibrium finder
once you've change
your abstraction otherwise
it's way too slow.
So, we first had
warm starting algorithms
that relied on
a particular kind of
equilibrium finding algorithm.
Now, we can do general warm
starts for CFR algorithms.
So, no matter where the
initial strategies came from,
from a different
equilibrium finder,
from human intuition,
whatever, we can now
start CFR with those.
So, you don't have to
start from scratch.
CFR is a counterfactual
regret minimization.
Then, new fastest algorithm
for the CFR family.
So, turns out that
in the CFR family,
CFR+ has for a few years now
been basically unbeatable,
and a lot of people have
tried to come up
with new variants of
the CFR family and
they've all been
either way slower than CFR+
or a little bit slower.
But now, we have something as
faster as we're planning
to submit within a month.
Then, regret
decomposition framework.
I mentioned that in CFR,
you are actually
decomposing the regret,
so that you can do
regret minimization
separately into information sets.
But turns out that
the way to do it
in CFR is not the only way.
There's actually
this infinite family
of exact decompositions
you can do,
and now you can go
beyond the CFR family.
And again, there, you can get
better algorithms than
in the CFR framework.
Then, equilibrium-finding
algorithms by
developing new theory of
gradient-based techniques.
So, gradient-based
techniques have
better worse case convergence
rates in CFR by a lot,
but in practice, CFR
has been faster.
It's kind of a mystery, and
it's still kind of true,
but now we're within
a factor of four of
CFR speed with these types
of algorithms as well.
Algorithms for
equilibrium refinements.
We talked about mostly
Nash equilibrium today.
But Nash equilibrium
doesn't play optimally if
the opponent or we
have made a mistake
in the game so far.
That's where equilibrium
refinements come in.
They're basically
additional constraints
on what counts as
a good solution.
Just to pick one
here, this last one,
trembling hand
refinements are maybe
the most famous family of those,
and they had been very
hard to compute even
for tiny games and
numerically unstable.
So, now, we have
algorithms that compute
trembling hand refinements for
games with about 10,000,
maybe 30,000 nodes.
So, still way less scalable,
but several orders of magnitude
more scalable than before.
Equilibrium-finding
algorithms for two agents,
that's still way less scalable.
We have the fastest one
currently for normal-form games.
So, matrix form games,
and how it works is that we're
doing a tree search not in
the space of
the discrete supports of
the actions as to what
actions are in play,
like we and others
have tried before,
but in the space of
the continuous probabilities.
So, we basically split
the probability space into
this hyper rectangles,
and then we have an oracle
which checks whether
hyper rectangle can potentially
have an equilibrium in it,
in this non-linear problem
of more than two agents.
Then, for exploration,
exploitation versus
exploitability.
I've had this on the slide for-
in my thoughts for
a long time now,
and we still haven't
really cracked it,
but I can say a few
interesting things about it.
So, in reinforcement learning,
there's this trade-off
between exploration
and exploitation.
In games, there's also
this third dimension
of exploitability.
As I start to exploit,
how much do I open myself
up to exploitation?
The folk wisdom
had been that if I
exploit more than any game
theoretic strategy would,
any Nash equilibrium
strategy would,
then I'm opening myself
to exploitation.
Turns out not true. You can
actually completely safely
exploit your opponent
by more than
that up to a bound
which we characterize.
It's actually has
a nice intuition in that,
I can't really- well,
let me say what
doesn't work first.
So, you might think that I
can take the winnings that I
have from Eric so far,
and I can bankroll
my exploitation.
I can exploit him so much
that I might lose up to
what I've already won.
Seems like that might be safe,
but it's not safe
because I'm walking with
my upside and my downside
from an ex-ante perspective
is still all there.
So, I need to be able to
separate out what I've
won based on luck
versus Eric's mistakes.
If I can lower bound how much
I've won based on
Eric's mistakes,
that is the amount that I can
use to bankroll
my exploitation in the future.
Then, a final thing on
this slide is depth
limited solving in
imperfect information games.
So, we talked about
sub-game solving,
but that was solving
the end of the game.
Now, we can actually
solve the beginning
and the middle as
well on the fly.
The idea that doesn't
work here is to say,
that I'm going to fix
the opponent strategy at
the leaf to what
they would play in
the blueprint because that
gives me too much power.
Instead, I'm going
to give the opponent
one final action at each leaf.
It's each leaf information set
and there they can choose
which strategy to play.
That takes away that extra power
and that is the idea
based on which we
can do depth limited
solving in imperfect
information games.
And these are still
theoretical guarantees and this
created the bot
moricom in my lab,
which was created on one server,
and to our knowledge,
it's the second best AI
for this problem.
All right. So,
commercial applications.
Well, I think that
most real-world settings
are imperfect information games,
although they're not
treated as such.
Now, that we have
this type of technology,
I think we're going to start
to see applications where
things are really treated
as games for what they are.
So, one example is
strategic pricing.
Typically, when
companies do pricing,
they optimize their prices
given their competitors
price is fixed.
Single-agent problem, but
in reality, of course,
the competitors change the prices
and you don't want to be
just pre-optimizing to
that and being reactive,
you want to think about
these things ahead.
Same in strategic product
portfolio optimization.
Gaming, video games,
training, streams,
you can make really
exciting streams by having
these superhuman AIs play against
each other. Bot detection.
Turns out that they have moves
that you must never play,
and there are millions of them,
and you can detect bots not
just by looking at
the operating system level,
but really from
the strategies themselves.
Automated negotiation,
electricity markets,
various aspects of finance,
investment banking,
political campaigns,
how do you spend media
against an adversary,
business strategy.
Hey, wouldn't it be
nice if there were
actually some strategy
in business strategy?
Bidding. How do you bid?
For example for oil tracts,
and then, once you
know how to bid,
you can actually evaluate
auction designs that you couldn't
normally evaluate because
you cancel for equilibrium.
Strategic market segmentation.
Same thing as with pricing.
Typically, market
segmentation has
been created as a static problem.
Of course, you have to think
about strategically how would
the competitors change
their strategies.
Change their segmentation
in the future.
Interaction between vehicles
and autonomous fleets.
So, let's say that you have
two operators of
autonomous fleets in the future.
The rules of the road put
limits on what they can do,
but there are a lot of
unspecified things,
like how do we
merge, for example.
Wouldn't it be nice if we
wouldn't have to negotiate
those in some ad
hoc way on the fly,
but there are too many
negotiation situations
to manually negotiate in advance.
So, you would want to
somehow automate that.
Acquisition strategy
like movie rights.
How should streaming
company buy movies,
which movies should they bid for,
in what order should they
buy them from the movie studios,
what should they offer, and
so on. Sports of course.
Lots of sports applications
and maybe the most radical,
it's got a long story,
but steering evolution
and biological adaptation
strategically.
For example, for medical
treatment planning or
synthetic biology.
Then there's a bunch of
government applications.
So, if you think about it,
traditionally in
military planning,
whether it's cybersecurity or
actual physical
military or whatever,
you assume a naive opponent,
a naive red, a fixed strategy.
You assign a strategy
and then you simulate
against that or do
war gaming against that.
Here, unlike simulation,
red strategy is not input
but is rather output.
So, you're actually looking at
all of the possible opponents
strategies and so you're robust,
and that is a bunch of
applications. Thank you very much.
>> In curiosity, you would
need your subgame innovations to
approximate good jobs in
those open world, messy spaces.
It seems more of it's
in generically looking
at game theoretic
approaches in these spaces,
or have you seen
the actual application of
the nuances of the way you solve
the two player poker game?
>> Yes.
>> That's used for an open world.
>> Yes. So, there's always
a question of modeling,
and when we think about
business strategy for
these two startups,
we're looking at what
are the closest,
where we can say, "Okay,
well, we have pretty
good models."
You start from there.
Good models and
close to zero sum or
exactly zero sum.
So, you're really looking at
very adversarial situations,
high-stakes, of course,
and once where the
Rumsfeld unknown unknowns
are not that big a deal.
But now, modeling is really,
I would say the number
one bottleneck here,
is that if the real world is
such that you can't really
model it accurately,
that is the number
one show stopper.
>> It's like a pretty big show
stopping for what?
>> Real world application?
>> Well, I'm not sure.
There's infinitely
many real world applications
and probably infinitely
many that you can model.
So, while it's a worry,
I'm not really worried.
The other is the
abstraction techniques.
Now, if you can bound
the difference between
the real world and the model,
you can say that, "Hey,
even if you solve just the model,
you're close optimal
for the real world."
>> Okay. Open
questions. Yeah, Paul.
>> So, part of
the game theory approaches
the idea that even if
your opponent knows your policy
right, they wouldn't
change anything.
Have you tried this with the
humans in the sense that,
if you have a probability
of a range of hands,
then you can actually
expose that to
the humans because they still
know what action you took,
and actually start reflecting
the internal state of
the bot to them, right?
So, the bot would actually say,
"Here's the hands I puts you on."
That's effectively a summary of
the policy from the point
of view of them.
They don't know what
actually took after that.
Have you tried to
seeing that and see how
they adapt or learn
based on that?
>> No, but we've done
something similar.
Eric and I were chatting a little
bit about this on
the fireside chat.
So, again, this comes to
people believing in people.
So, we got in the poker already
before this event for
the last few years before that,
the last couple at least.
It was a situation where when
human expert poker players
would tell us,
"Okay, they're bot
both made a mistake."
Chances were much
higher than they were
wrong than that the bot
had made a mistake.
What we did, I had
Chris Ferguson,
who's a really kind of
a mathematical PhD level guy,
who's a top poker player,
look at these situations where
somebody told us that
"Hey, that was a mistake."
Then we would give him
the belief distributions,
and the path, and everything.
He would actually write
these little essays
that tell what happen
in every time.
It's just like
super human reasoning.
In his words, he was thinking
like two levels deeper
than any human,
and at once he had three days
to think about it.
Actually, that was
a brilliant move, not a mistake.
But sometimes, they look weird,
like one happened
during the play.
We had the AI called,
I think maybe it was all
in or some other huge,
huge pot called, a huge
bet with Jack High.
Most people who play
poker would say,
"I thought they, well,
that was a mistake."
But turns out that exactly with
that Jack and that other card,
maybe it was a three or whatever.
That is exactly with what you do,
you play the light call
just with that,
because you have
to light call with
something and with the blockers,
that was exactly the antidote
to light call with.
You don't do it with 100 percent,
you do it for some percent,
which was not near zero,
but once he really
thought that through,
he actually saw
the merit in that.
>> Is there a rule of machine
learning like you're listening,
like your doctor or
[inaudible] right?
Now, you have this
really good poker players.
Does it help you, for
example, in addition to that,
like you're solving it
in a very strong manner,
but does it help in compute,
maybe like the first part
when you're doing
the abstraction,
and then there's
many months or when you use
thousand CPU cycles to drive
like learn from expert
for demonstrations,
and then do the compute upwards
such seated right back,
or is that not still
a viable strategy?
>> I see at least three roles.
One is that, we now have
the reef warm starts techniques.
So, you can actually warm
start from any strategy,
no matter how it's computed.
Whether it's computed
with machine learning
or some guy just thought
that that was a good idea.
It doesn't matter. We can
warm start from that.
The second is that,
when we do opponent exploitation.
Those techniques, which
we didn't use here,
but those techniques you
could think of those as
machine learning
techniques which are
kind of fortified by game
theoretic reasoning,
and there's definitely a role
for machine learning and data.
Then the third is the modelling.
So, I have to believe
that machine learning which
is all backward-looking,
and strategic reasoning which
is all forward-looking.
They have to be
somehow synergistic.
One of the ways that those
are synergistic, I think,
is that machine learning can
be used to learn the model,
or aspects of the model.
Like for example,
chance probabilities
which are not strategic
or what moves are plausible,
or things like that.
>> Have you tried
to bring this system
yet in the tournament
where your early rounds
at tournaments
are all about exploitation,
so that you can chip up and
then have the chip advantage.
How does it actually performs
in a multiplayer situations?
>> Yeah. We we
haven't really played
tournaments and we haven't
played multiplayer.
We have a couple of players,
early papers a long time ago
on three-player jump
fall tournaments,
like three player in
games of tournaments.
But we haven't really looked at
that tournament play per say.
One thing I can say is that,
when it comes to not tournaments
but multiplayer,
I hear from a lot of botters.
Not academics but botters.
That the way they generate
the top ports today,
for let's say six max.
They're very much
the same techniques.
So, while in theory,
there's this big complexity gap
between two players
zero sum games,
and more general games,
in practice,
at least for poker, it seems
that the same techniques do
well even in those
more general settings.
Yeah.
>> So, your original blueprints
is over some abstraction
but it's Nash, right?
>> It's an approximate Nash
for some abstraction, yes.
>> So, even in that,
I guess for any coarse
or fine abstraction,
at least in poker,
it seems once you
have a good model,
the right move is,
I wouldn't say immediate but at
least computable
or you could say,
"This is the right move
distribution."
But I guess in real life,
even if I know the right move
is to exit the room,
it takes a lot of actuator to
actually affect that goal, right?
So, like I guess there are
settings where you have to
go but it takes
some extra mileage to actually
reach that goal, right?
I think in poker, it's more
immediate where I need to make
this move and you could directly
affect that move for it.
But I think, how do
you reason about that,
where even if the model of
the world is taken
to reach some goal,
there needs to be
some kind of planning or
learning how to actually perform
the action that do it, right?
It's kind of like, "I
know the best thing to do
is if I take my three point
shots here but I can't do it,
because I cannot make
the shot very right."
How do you reason about that?
>> Yeah. Well, we don't.
You're right, we don't.
When we take an action,
it's not like robotics where
there's slippage and whatever.
>> Right.
>> It's like when we take
an action, that action happens.
>> Yes.
>> But I'll take issue
with the first part
which is at somehow when
you get the abstraction,
it somehow immediate with
the probability should be.
That's very hard to compute
with algorithms that had
been developed over 14,
15 years on a
supercomputer for months.
So, it's not immediate.
>> Yeah, but it's
computable, right?
So, I mean there will be
cases for this system,
no matter how much you compute
this, it's non-computable, right?
How do you reason about them?
>> Yes. I'm personally
not that interested
in that question.
>> Yeah, I asked.
>> But I can tell you
some things that people
have done for this,
for example, game
theoretic strategies under
execution uncertainty.
There are a few papers on that,
for example, for Bill Gates.
>> I see.
>> But not from my group.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> Let's stop there,
and thank you.
>> Thank you.